[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben heute machen wir eine
no-bike Kinder country Torte und wisst
ihr was ich habe richtig Bock drauf
deswegen lege ich jetzt auch direkt los
es wird auch ein recht schnelles Rezept
okay bei der Kühlzeit muss man so ein
bisschen Geduld haben aber es ist echt
easy peasy und sie wird sehr cool
aussehen ich gebe jetzt erstmal meine
Butterkekse mein Mixer und falls ihr
kein Mixer habt könnt ihr auch einfach
ein Gefrierbeutel nehmen ein bisschen
Aggression rauslassen und dann einfach
zu kleinen kümmelchen verarbeiten und
meine Butter habe ich in der Mikrowelle
schon geschmolzen bei geringerer Zahl
damit auch nicht platzt und das werde
ich gleich Vereinen aber um einen
dunklen Boden zu bekommen könnt ihr ganz
einfachen Trick anwenden einfach ein
bisschen Backkakao gleich hinzufügen
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt hier erstmal einen
cakeboard eigentlich kennt ihr das auch
für mich war eigentlich immer direkt auf
der Tortenplatte aber ich muss sagen
dieser Mädchen unsicher welche Farbe ich
nehmen soll das ist immer mein struggle
deshalb jetzt erstmal ein cakeboard dann
kann ich das einfach immer noch
entscheiden so Tortenring gebe ich jetzt
hier ein noch 20 cm
zack hier einmal fixieren und dann
einmal auf mein cakeboard so und jetzt
macht ihr nicht erst den Boden rein also
heute so gefühlt alles anders wir nehmen
uns jetzt erstmal Kinder Country und ich
muss mich richtig zusammenrechnen ich
liebe Kinder country fun fact ich habe
wirklich mal ein so eine ganze Packung
weggehauen
unnormal einfach lecker ich ich liebe
ich könnte wirklich
jeden Tag Kinder essen das ist wirklich
Fakt jetzt nehmen wir uns immer die
Riegel und machen uns die hier so an den
Rand eigentlich stehen die auch also tut
mir jetzt irgendwie gerade gar nicht um
finde ich total praktisch und wenn ihr
dann einmal drumherum seid dann kommt
der Boden rein und den müsst ihr dann
unbedingt sehr sehr feste andrücken also
die Cerealien die müssen immer in die
gleiche Richtung gucken es wird ja
ausgelacht für meinen inneren Mong aber
ganz ehrlich wenn man schon die
Möglichkeit hat die Cerealien alle in
die gleiche Richtung nämlich nach nach
oben
zu lassen machen wir das doch
[Musik]
so ich bin jetzt angelangt bei meinem
letzten Kindergarten wie sonst sage ich
immer ihr könnt auch eine Springform
aber ich muss sagen es ist einfach super
praktisch denn jetzt muss ich meinen
Kinder country also den letzten nicht
zurechtschneiden sondern habe richtig
schick hier einfach ein bisschen
vergrößert macht wieder eng
so und dann seid ihr jetzt nicht ganz
bei 20 cm was ja gar nicht schlimm ist
sondern bei so ungefähr nicht ganz ein
20 aber so passt jedes Kinder country
perfekt rein und ihr habt optisch
wirklich eine 1+ mit Sternchen
[Musik]
so jetzt machen wir die leckere
Cremefüllung ich habe mich für so eine
locker leichte frische Creme entschieden
und zwar mit Vanillegeschmack ich weiß
den Kindergarten Vanillegeschmack aber
ich würde mir wünschen aber Kinder kann
ja auch also ich finde es sticht
Schokolade eher hervor als irgendeine
Creme daher haben wir auch den Schoko
Keksboden und wir bekommen natürlich
auch noch einen schokoabschluss und die
Creme darf dann ruhig vanillig sein ich
habe jetzt hier Doppelrahmfrischkäse ich
persönlich nehme da gerne einfach
original für delfia weil der sehr
salzarm schmeckt aber wenn ihr eine
Alternative habt schreibt mir gerne mal
in die Kommentare so und da gebe ich
jetzt kalte Schlagsahne dazu ich muss
sagen alle Zutaten sind kalt weil nur
dann funktioniert das so kalte
Schlagsahne zum kalten Frischkäse da
könnt ihr dann auch schon Zucker mit
dazugeben ich habe jetzt kein
Puderzucker weil wir werden das ganze ja
gleich eh eine längere Zeit kühlen
lassen und dann löst sich der Zucker
auch schön auf und es gibt eine schöne
Konsistenz und hier kommt noch mal
Vanilleextrakt zum Einsatz das macht
eigentlich den ganzen Geschmack aus die
Basis ist halt einfach nur frisch durch
den Frischkäse die Sahne und gleich
kommt noch Quark zum Einsatz jetzt
verrühre ich das aber erstmal ihr könnt
natürlich eure Handrührgerät verwenden
wenn jetzt keine Küchenmaschine habt
erstmal auf niedriger Stufe langsam
verrühren damit es sich verbindet dann
immer schneller werden und Sahnefest
einrieseln lassen und ganz zum Schluss
habe ich hier noch 20% den Quark den
rührt ihr ganz kurz ein nur drei bis
vier Sekunden und dann ist die Creme
fertig
[Musik]
so wir sind schon fast oben angekommen
hier an der Oberfläche jetzt kommt
einfach noch die Creme rein und die
Oberfläche habe ich ja gesagt werde ich
gleich noch mit einer Schokoglasur
Ausschnitten ich finde die Creme einfach
genial die ist so da ist zwar Quark drin
nicht ganz so mega festes aber durch die
aufgeschlagene Sahne durch den festen
Frischkäse daher bitte auch keine
fettarme Variante oder so nehmen weil
sonst wird das flüssig durch die
Komponenten ist die Creme jetzt schon
relativ fest aber wird natürlich noch
fester und halt schnittfähig na damit
man auch schöne Stücke rausschneiden
kann wenn man es halt kühlt daher jetzt
hier schön glatt verstreichen dann kommt
die Schokoglasur oben drauf mit den
Cerealien und dann brauchen wir ganz
viel Geduld bei der Kühlzeit
[Musik]
so die Torte ist immer noch hier sich
zwischendurch auch gar nicht weil da
kommt der gleich die Kühlzeit und jetzt
machen wir unseren Guss aus vier Zutaten
ich habe hier Vollmilch Kuvertüre mit
meinem Kinder country ist es ja auch
Vollmilch und ich Zartbitter ihr könntet
jetzt aber auch Zartbitter nehmen wenn
ihr unbedingt möchtet dann habe ich hier
Butter und Sahne die zwei Zutaten
brauchen wir einfach für die Konsistenz
damit es nicht so ein harter knackguss
wird sondern so ein so ein Softair Guss
und da kommt noch diese leckeren Kellogs
Max rein ich muss echt zugeben ich habe
keine Kellogs Mix gefunden ich habe
dinkelpuffer genommen aber ist ja nicht
schlimm hauptsache sie schmecken so und
das ganze mache ich gleich hier einfach
auf dem Herz nicht zu heiß damit die
nichts verbrennt sondern einfach ganz
langsam die Milch erwärmen Butter
schmelzen Milch diese Sahne die Sahne
erwärmen nicht hoch kochen sondern
wirklich nur erwärmen das ist ganz ganz
wichtig weil wenn es hochkocht dann
machen viele immer den Fehler dann wird
der Bus nicht mehr so wie sein soll
[Musik]
und
ja was sagst du also man muss auch die
Optik bewerten zehn von zehn optisch
also ich finde das richtig cool ich
finde es auch cool
da oben ne also mein Tipp noch
anders gewesen also die ist nicht gleich
man kann ja immer so mehrere Varianten
halt machen ich gebe euch noch einen
Tipp wenn ihr schneidet nimmt am besten
ich habe dieses Tortenmesser wo die eine
Seite glatt ist und die anderen
als wäre das Fest oder hart aber ist es
gar nicht aber es ist halt besser damit
ihr euch das nicht so runterdrückt ja
dann mal gönnen oder mal probieren ja
genommen
die Hälfte hat es ist ja eine hohe Torte
der Boden ist geil man hat den recht
wenn man wirklich dann Frühstück ein
country hat alles zu nehmen aber so
heftig also richtig lecker
auf dem Teller dann kann man davon echt
besser
aber sehr frisch und positiv gemeint
weil eigentlich mich gefragt hat immer
so ein säuerlichen Geschmack deswegen
habe ich auch extra 20% hingenommen und
der schmeckt so richtig also die Creme
schmeckt übertrieben
natürlich gekühlt da ist die Kühlzeit
schon mindestens 4 Stunden gerne auch
über Nacht und dann könnt ihr das
einfach nur weiter einfach nur
reinpfeifen und genießen mit echt geil
auch einer meiner liebsten Ferrero
Torten muss ich sagen von allen so viel
rotorten ist die schon mal mein
Highlight eines meiner Highlight weil
ich habe echt viele schon gemacht ja auf
jeden Fall wollen wir es so ganz in die
Länge ziehen wir wünschen euch viel Spaß
beim Nachmachen solltet ihr Fragen haben
schreibt es mir unten in die Kommentare
und äh haben sie beantwortet euch dann
gerne
sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten Mal
tschüss
[Musik]